je veux juste une blonde juste la suite
si le monde elle va au cinéma vous
joindre à nous ce serait un ticket s'il
vous plaît la dame lui donna ticket elle
s'en va elle revient vais juste me 30
secondes après bonjour madame je
voudrais un ticket s'il vous plaît ne me
donne un ticket dieu peut-être un copain
qui arrivait derrière un trio revient 2
3 4 secondes plus tard je voudrais un
ticket s'il vous plaît à 2 cm excusez
moi mais je vous en ai déjà vendu de la
wii mais à chaque fois que je rentre
dans la salle ya un mec qui me force à
13 enfants et je pense que liane et on
forme parce qu'après ce qu'elle a vu cet
après midi je pense que ça l'a
l'ensemble je vous raconte j'ai fait une
caméra cachée avec elle pour la grande
race rats et je vous racontais paul
pietsch vous le verrez bientôt dans la
prochaine loi grâce à s'aimer c'est
inoubliable on est tranquillement dans
mon bureau j'ai appelé pour faire un
rendez vous est donc moi je suis de doha
la vitre ayant un mec qui arrive et qui
vient faire la vitre ne connais pas moi
juste sa tête
donc il fait la vie comme ça ok diatta
il ya un mec qui fait la vie de la série
mais un moment où on lève le mec est le
mec est à poil
donc moi je le vois pas et elle me dit
un mec derrière toi à poil en train de
faire les vitres vous verrez ça dans la
grande rade mais quand je dis mais t'es
juste on retourne toi c'est vrai qu'ils
étaient légers tout poil lui il le ton
qui se retourne tu parles l'oreillette
tout éloigne chine il a disparu
donc il prend pour une folle donc elle
va mais c'était bien agréable elle a vu
d ici
merci beaucoup merci où il faisait bon
flipper une blonde qui arrive à la
bibliothèque ici bonjour mademoiselle je
voudrais un big mac et trois frites si
vous voulez je fis moselle vous êtes
dans une bibliothèque est fait en
partant je voudrais un pic pratique
[Applaudissements]
j'aime bien un truc eux
donc c'est une blonde des allers retours
c'est une blonde qui châtient jti qui
est dans un magasin qui fait des allers
retours depuis plus là la vendeuse vers
l'avant a dit mais ça fait une heure que
vous fait des allers-retours qu'est ce
que vous cherchez elle ne cherche un
déodorant pour mon mari est laborieuse
du deal utilise un déodorant à boules à
lui dire non pour les bras
[Applaudissements]